the final stop on Vladimir zielenski's
tour of Europe's big four economic
powers
after a weekend in Rome Berlin and Paris
it was the warm embrace of Checkers on
Monday the country residents of British
prime minister Rishi sunak Winston
Churchill made many of his famous
speeches in World War II from this run
the complex three-day Security operation
for face time with these European
leaders has paid off for zelenski the UK
joined France and Germany's weekend
pledges by promising hundreds of air
defense missiles and armed drones just
days after it donated long-range cruise
missiles we're a temple from all our
hearts from ukrainians all the equipment
will be used in Ukraine's anticipated
spring counter-offensive but in reality
trips like these for zelenski are about
securing the next donations and top of
his list are F-16 fighter jets today we
spoke about the Jets and I see that in
the closest time you will hear some I
think very important decisions neither
the UK nor Canada own f-16s but the U.S
Poland and others do zelenski wants a
coalition of countries to help Ukraine
with the complex training and
infrastructure that the planes would
need
French president Emmanuel macron says he
is on board a spokesperson for Canada's
Minister for National Defense Anita
Anand told Global News only that she
remains in close contact with Ukrainian
officials about their most pressing
security needs no country has yet gone
really serious with looking into how and
when such delivery would be possible so
the timeline is is open but it will be
months at the earliest before any f-16s
are patrolling Ukrainian Skies an
acknowledgment from zelenski that even
if the upcoming counter-offensive is a
success it is unlikely to end the war 4.
Redmond Shannon double news London